Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. up for the adventure. This iconic, award-winning vehicle has been redefined with a distinctive, modern design. A reimagined exterior features compelling proportions and precise detailing.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。准备好迎接冒险了吗？这款标志性的获奖车型以独特、现代的设计进行了重新定义。重新构想的外观具有引人注目的比例和精确的细节。
Built with integrity and purpose, the interior boasts robust, durable materials. Whether it's the all-terrain capability, ample cargo capacity, or innovative camera technology, the Defender 110 lets you go further and do more. And with seating for up to seven, everyone can enjoy the journey. Learn more at Land land rover.ca broken spears lie in the roads we have torn our hair in grief the houses are roofless now and their walls are reddened with blood. Worms are swarming in the streets and plazas and the walls are splattered with gore. The water has turned red as if it were died and when we drink it, it has the taste of brine. We have pounded our hands in despair against the adobe walls for our inheritance. Our city is lost and dead. The shields of our warriors were its defense but they could
内饰秉承诚信与宗旨，采用了坚固耐用的材料。无论是全地形能力、充足的载货空间，还是创新的摄像头技术，卫士 110（Defender 110）都能让您走得更远，做得更多。最多可容纳七人，让每个人都能享受旅程。欲了解更多信息，请访问 Landrover.ca。破碎的长矛躺在路上，我们因悲伤而揪断了头发，房屋如今已没有屋顶，墙壁被鲜血染红。蠕虫在街道和广场上成群结队，墙壁上溅满了血迹。水变成了红色，仿佛被染过一样，当我们喝它时，有一种咸味。我们绝望地用手捶打着土墙，为了我们的遗产。我们的城市已经失落并死亡。我们战士的盾牌曾是它的防御，但它们却
not save it we have chewed dry twigs and salt grasses we have filled our mouths with dust and bits of adobe we have eaten lizards rats and worms that was a translation of a now what lament probably written in the 1540s. And the phrase broken spears, it's been described as perhaps the most famous Nahuatl phrase in English because it was used as the title of the translation of a book by the Mexican historian Miguel León Portillo. But Dominic, would you like me to do a linguistic deep dive here even if you don't i'm still going to do it i'm just going to say yes then because apparently broken spears is a mistranslation really it should actually be shattered bones shattered bones and the reason
无法拯救它。我们咀嚼着干树枝和咸草，我们嘴里塞满了灰尘和土块，我们吃着蜥蜴、老鼠和蠕虫。那是一段纳瓦特尔语（Nahuatl）哀歌的翻译，可能写于 16 世纪 40 年代。“破碎的长矛”这个短语，被描述为英语中最著名的纳瓦特尔语短语，因为它被用作墨西哥历史学家米格尔·莱昂-波蒂利亚（Miguel León-Portilla）所著书籍译本的标题。但是多米尼克，你想让我在这里进行一次语言学深度解析吗？即使你不想，我还是会做的。那我还是说“愿意”吧，因为显然“破碎的长矛”是一个误译，实际上它应该是“破碎的骨头”。破碎的骨头，原因
i know this is because it's a footnote in camilla townsend's wonderful book fifth son yeah where she discusses it so we like to go deep, don't we, in this podcast? And I hope that people will be impressed with my command of now what Spanish-English translation. Tom, what's lovely about your linguistic analysis here is this is the first time in this mighty series that we've had an introduction that I didn't write. Okay. Yes. And that's commendably modest on your part because of course we're doing this series because your new book for children, The Fall of the Aztecs is out. And I guess that after the seven episodes we've had, I mean, it puts in perspective perhaps the challenge of rendering this story, not just for children, but for adults as entertainment. Because on one level, I mean, there's no question, it's unbelievably entertaining, dramatic, extraordinary story, the inspiration for so much science fiction that has been written since. On another level, I mean, it is a deeply
我知道这一点是因为卡米拉·汤森（Camilla Townsend）那本精彩的著作《第五个儿子》（Fifth Son）中有一个脚注，她在书中讨论了这个问题。所以我们喜欢在这个播客中深入挖掘，不是吗？我希望人们会对我在纳瓦特尔语到西班牙语再到英语翻译方面的造诣印象深刻。汤姆，你在这里的语言分析很棒，这是在这个宏大的系列节目中，第一次出现我没有参与撰写的介绍。好的。而且你表现得非常谦虚，因为我们制作这个系列节目当然是因为你为孩子们写的新书《阿兹特克的陨落》（The Fall of the Aztecs）出版了。我想在经历了这七集之后，这或许能让我们从一个角度看待讲述这个故事的挑战，不仅是为孩子，也是为成年人作为娱乐内容。因为在某种程度上，毫无疑问，这是一个令人难以置信的娱乐性、戏剧性、非凡的故事，也是后来许多科幻小说创作的灵感来源。但在另一个层面上，它是一个极其
traumatic narrative, isn't it? And the horrors with which it culminates, you know, brains splattered and hair torn out in grief and all that i mean this is very upsetting and unsettling i think there are two dimensions to this tom so at one level you can say that's all history to some extent isn't it of course people are fascinated with history we read it for pleasure so many of us but so often what it describes is very dark and people are always drawn to the extremes that That's why books on the world wars are so successful. Well, I suppose, but I suppose also the sacking of cities. I mean, it lies at the heart of the two great traditions that underpin the West's cultural
创伤性的叙事，不是吗？它最终导致的恐怖，你知道，脑浆四溅，因悲伤而揪断头发等等，我认为这非常令人不安和困扰。汤姆，我认为这有两个维度。在某种程度上，你可以说这在某种程度上就是历史，不是吗？当然，人们对历史着迷，我们为了消遣而阅读它，我们中的许多人都是如此，但它所描述的往往非常黑暗，人们总是被极端事物所吸引。这就是为什么关于世界大战的书籍如此成功。嗯，我想是这样，但我想还有城市的洗劫。它位于支撑西方文化遗产的两大传统的核心，
inheritance, the Greek and the biblical. Yeah. The sacking of Troy, the sacking of Jerusalem. Yes. But also, Tom, I mean, any history, but whether it be for children or for adults, actually, there's a balance between kind of prurient voyeurism, pornography of violence, I suppose you might call it, and being sufficiently sensitive and respectful towards people in the past whose lives were destroyed.
希腊传统和圣经传统。是的。特洛伊的洗劫，耶路撒冷的洗劫。是的。但汤姆，任何历史，无论是为孩子还是为成人写的，实际上，在某种程度上，在窥淫癖、暴力色情（如果你愿意这么称呼的话）与对过去那些生活被摧毁的人们保持足够的敏感和尊重之间，存在着一种平衡。
The other element, of course, is that this has an additional dimension in recent years, because this is one of the great foundational moments of European colonialism. So it carries a kind of charge now that it might not have done 50 years ago, certainly in the West. Except that it does come to carry a charge in Protestant countries, doesn't it? So we, as English speakers, are heirs to that Protestant tradition. The black legend, Tom. The black legend. Yes.
当然，另一个因素是，近年来这有了额外的维度，因为这是欧洲殖民主义伟大的奠基时刻之一。所以它现在带有一种 50 年前可能没有的色彩，至少在西方是这样。除非它在新教国家确实带有这种色彩，不是吗？所以我们作为英语使用者，是那个新教传统的继承者。黑色传说，汤姆。黑色传说。是的。
In which what the Spanish do in Mexico, oddly drawing on Spanish witnesses. I mean, so Bartolomé Las Casas, the friar whose records of Spanish atrocities we have cited regularly throughout these episodes, but Protestants draw on this to construct an image of the Spanish as uniquely oppressive and satanic. Yes. So to mention two writers that we've talked about a lot in this series, if people want a sense of the kind of debate, they could just read a book by Matthew Restle, on the one hand, who emphasises what he sees as the near-genocidal approach of the Spaniards. And then you read Fernando Cervantes on the other, who is very keen to dispel what he sees as the black legend, and to say the Spanish are not uniquely greedy and rapacious
在这种传说中，西班牙人在墨西哥所做的事情，奇怪地借鉴了西班牙目击者的记录。我的意思是，巴托洛梅·德拉斯·卡萨斯（Bartolomé de las Casas），那位我们在这些剧集中经常引用其关于西班牙暴行记录的修士，但新教徒利用这一点构建了一个西班牙人是极其压迫和邪恶的形象。是的。所以提到我们在本系列中谈论很多的两位作家，如果人们想了解这种辩论，他们可以阅读马修·雷斯特尔（Matthew Restall）的书，他强调了他所认为的西班牙人近乎种族灭绝的做法。然后你再读费尔南多·塞万提斯（Fernando Cervantes）的书，他非常热衷于消除他所认为的“黑色传说”，并说西班牙人并不像 16 世纪以来的新教作家所描绘的那样贪婪、掠夺
and sadistic as they were painted by Protestant writers from the 16th century onwards. And so to what extent do you think the tradition exemplified today by Matthew Restle today, he's writing in English. I mean, he is English. He's not writing as a practicing Protestant. But to what extent do you think the sense of the Spanish conquest as something to be condemned is an inheritance of those deep, deep Protestant traditions? That's a good question. I mean, it's dressed up in progressive rather than Protestant language, isn't it? But the themes are quite similar. The themes are similar, right. And the Protestant tradition of the Black Legend,
和残忍。那么你认为今天以马修·雷斯特尔为代表的传统在多大程度上是那些深厚的新教传统的遗产？他现在用英语写作。我的意思是，他是英国人。他不是以一个虔诚的新教徒身份写作。但你认为将西班牙征服视为一种应受谴责的事物的观念，在多大程度上是那些深厚的新教传统的遗产？这是一个好问题。我的意思是，它被包装在进步的语言而不是新教的语言中，不是吗？但主题非常相似。主题相似，没错。而“黑色传说”的新教传统，
the idea of the Spanish as greedy and sinister and sadistic, has had a long afterlife. That said, when you go into the details of the conquest and then what happens immediately afterwards... They are dark. They are pretty dark. Okay, so should we get into them and then perhaps we come back to looking at how this story has been processed and understood over the centuries? So we ended last time, Tom. We're in August 1521. The city of Tenochtitlan has fallen, but of course, history doesn't stop there. Actually, there's one thing that Camilla Townsend's book, Fifth Son, is brilliant at saying. It's brilliant on that, isn't it? People don't say, oh gosh, this is the end of a chapter in history. The Spanish conquest has
即西班牙人贪婪、阴险和残忍的观念，有着漫长的余波。话虽如此，当你深入了解征服以及随后发生的事情时……它们是黑暗的。它们确实非常黑暗。好吧，那我们应该深入探讨一下，然后也许我们再回过头来看看这个故事在几个世纪以来是如何被处理和理解的？所以我们上次结束时，汤姆。我们是在 1521 年 8 月。特诺奇蒂特兰城已经陷落，但历史当然不会就此停止。实际上，卡米拉·汤森的书《第五个儿子》有一点说得非常精彩。它在这方面很出色，不是吗？人们不会说，哦天哪，这是历史篇章的终结。西班牙征服已经
happened. For a lot of people, life is rolling on with all its vicissitudes. Cortes is still desperate to find gold. The whole operation, the whole enterprise that he started all these years ago was based on making his investors, co-investors rich. And it's clear that he doesn't find as much gold as he wanted to. Quite quickly, the Spanish are beating and torturing their prisoners. Do they manage to dredge any out of the lake? I think they don't, actually. There's some indication they sent divers into the lake and they couldn't find it. Maybe it's lost. So it could be buried beneath the streets of Mexico City to this day. It could be conceivably because, of course,
发生了。对许多人来说，生活仍在继续，经历着各种变迁。科尔特斯仍然渴望找到黄金。他多年前开始的整个行动、整个事业，都是基于让他那些共同投资者致富。很明显，他没有找到他想要的那么多黄金。很快，西班牙人就开始殴打和折磨他们的俘虏。他们设法从湖里捞出什么了吗？我想他们没有，实际上。有迹象表明他们派潜水员进入湖中，但没能找到。也许它丢失了。所以它可能至今仍埋在墨西哥城的街道下。这完全有可能，因为当然，
that lake is now Mexico City. That's one of the extraordinary things that you go to Mexico City and you are walking over the lake on which these naval battles and things happened. So they don't find anything like the gold they expected. Some of Cortes' men mutter and grumble and say, well, Cortes and the captains have probably got it all for themselves. I mean, this is a standard kind of conquistador theme. The ferocity of the Spanish, I think, is partly explicable because of their frustration. They pillage some of the lakeside towns. There's stories about them setting dogs on priests and dignitaries and things in an attempt to torture out of them the location of all this hidden gold that they're convinced is there.
那个湖现在就是墨西哥城。这是非凡的事情之一，你去墨西哥城，你正走在发生这些海战等事件的湖面上。所以他们没有找到他们预期的那种黄金。科尔特斯的一些手下嘟囔着抱怨说，好吧，科尔特斯和船长们可能把所有东西都据为己有了。我的意思是，这是一种标准的征服者主题。我认为西班牙人的凶残部分可以用他们的挫败感来解释。他们洗劫了一些湖畔城镇。有关于他们为了拷问出所有这些他们确信存在的隐藏黄金的下落，而放狗去咬牧师和显贵等人的故事。
And this kind of lust for gold has been motivating them in their atrocities right from the beginning. Yeah. I'm quoting the Ennio Morricone soundtrack from The Good, the Bad and the Ugly. Very good. Very good. People say lust for gold. I mean, they want gold not because they have some peculiar fixation with gold, but because gold is divisible and portable. Can be transferred back to Spain. Exactly.
而这种对黄金的贪婪从一开始就一直在驱使他们进行暴行。是的。我引用的是埃尼奥·莫里康内（Ennio Morricone）为《黄金三镖客》（The Good, the Bad and the Ugly）创作的配乐。非常好。非常好。人们说对黄金的贪婪。我的意思是，他们想要黄金并不是因为他们对黄金有什么特殊的执念，而是因为黄金是可分割且易于携带的。可以转移回西班牙。没错。
They can transfer it back to Spain. It won't rot. It won't, you know, it's the best resource through which they can make themselves rich. But they just haven't got enough. Cuauhtémoc, after all those empty promises, Cortés tortures him, the emperor. They tie him to a pole. To find if he's buried gold. If he's buried gold.
他们可以把它转移回西班牙。它不会腐烂。它不会，你知道，它是他们能让自己致富的最佳资源。但他们就是没有足够的黄金。夸特莫克（Cuauhtémoc），在所有那些空头支票之后，科尔特斯折磨了他，这位皇帝。他们把他绑在柱子上。为了找到他是否埋藏了黄金。如果他埋藏了黄金。
They pour oil on his feet and they set his feet on fire. And the eyewitness account says he said nothing to them. He merely smiled as if he were taking a steam bath. And there were some amazing murals. We talked about these in one of our live shows, Tom. Yeah. The amazing murals by David Siguieros and other kind of Mexican muralists. These are in Mexico City.
他们把油倒在他的脚上，然后点火烧他的脚。目击者的记录说他什么也没对他们说。他只是微笑着，仿佛在洗蒸汽浴。有一些令人惊叹的壁画。我们在我们的一次现场节目中谈到过这些，汤姆。是的。大卫·西凯罗斯（David Siqueiros）和其他墨西哥壁画家的惊人壁画。这些都在墨西哥城。
And they show Cuauhtémoc being tortured by the Spaniards, and the Spaniards look like these terrifying kind of stormtrooper-like figures because these murals are done in the 1930s. And Melinche watching as well. Melinche watching through a sort of gap in the Spaniards' helmets. Cortés, meanwhile, he has established his headquarters, as we said last time, in Coyoacán. You can see his headquarters.
它们展示了夸特莫克被西班牙人折磨，而西班牙人看起来像那些可怕的冲锋队式的人物，因为这些壁画是 20 世纪 30 年代完成的。马林切（Malinche）也在观看。马林切透过西班牙人头盔的缝隙看着。与此同时，科尔特斯，正如我们上次所说，在科约阿坎（Coyoacán）建立了他的总部。你可以看到他的总部。
It's this kind of low-level, one-story, red-painted, very Spanish-looking kind of mansion complex. On one level, Cortes has been a great winner. All his gambles have paid off. There is talk that he is called your highness by his fellows. There's talk that he's going to award his captains knighthoods. There are even some rumors that he will call himself a king. He's so far away from Spain. Of course, he doesn't do that. He's always a bit anxious because of course he has broken the law. Right. And he has the fat and jolly Velazquez. Yeah, exactly. Exactly. Back in Cuba to deal with. I know, Tom, what you're thinking. You're thinking that you're Cortez and I'm Velazquez. Well, I'm not saying it, no. Yeah. You're cruel, rapacious,
这是一种低矮的、一层楼的、漆成红色的、看起来非常西班牙式的豪宅建筑群。在某种层面上，科尔特斯是一个伟大的赢家。他所有的赌注都赢了。有传言说他被同僚称为“殿下”。有传言说他要授予他的船长们爵位。甚至有传言说他会自称为国王。他离西班牙太远了。当然，他没有那样做。他总是有点焦虑，因为他当然触犯了法律。没错。而且他还要应付那个又胖又快乐的贝拉斯克斯（Velázquez）。是的，没错。没错。在古巴要处理。我知道你在想什么，汤姆。你在想你是科尔特斯，而我是贝拉斯克斯。好吧，我没说，没有。是的。你残忍、贪婪，
and ultimately a cold person. I'm a saying it, no. Yeah. You're cruel, rapacious, and ultimately a cold person. I'm a great hospitable guy. No, I was thinking more that I'm Moctezuma and you're Cortez. You're a formidable... You've taken me prisoner and forcing me to do endless episodes on the Aztecs. Yeah. That's so harsh because I'm desperate to do them as well. It's an unworthy joke. So when I'm gone, you'll say of me, ultimately a mediocre and dishonest man.
最终是一个冷酷的人。我没说，没有。是的。你残忍、贪婪，最终是一个冷酷的人。我是一个非常热情好客的人。不，我更多是在想我是蒙特祖马（Moctezuma），而你是科尔特斯。你是一个强大的……你把我俘虏了，强迫我做关于阿兹特克的无休止的剧集。是的。这太刻薄了，因为我也非常渴望做这些。这是一个不值得的笑话。所以当我离开时，你会说我，最终是一个平庸且不诚实的人。
A bad man. Yes. And a mediocre. Well, anyway, this particular mediocre man, although I don't think he is mediocre, I think he is a terrifyingly ruthless opportunist. So that autumn, to Velázquez's horror, Charles V confirms Cortés as governor, captain general. Because the scale of his achievement is evident, do you think?
一个坏人。是的。和一个平庸的人。好吧，无论如何，这个特定的平庸之人，虽然我不认为他是平庸的，我认为他是一个极其冷酷无情的机会主义者。所以那个秋天，令贝拉斯克斯惊恐的是，查理五世（Charles V）确认科尔特斯为总督、总队长。因为他成就的规模显而易见，你觉得呢？
Yes, I think he has no choice. Rather than the wealth that he's sending. I mean, he is sending some wealth. He's sending something. He's not sending nothing. But I think you're right. The stories that are going back to Europe, I mean, it must seem barely believable. Yeah. Is Cortés a hero across Europe? This is the interesting thing. Even at this point, it's not modern wokery to say Cortez is a very, very ambiguous, if not downright dislikable figure. Because even at the time,
是的，我认为他别无选择。而不是他送来的财富。我的意思是，他确实送来了一些财富。他送来了一些东西。他不是什么都没送。但我认为你是对的。传回欧洲的故事，我的意思是，这一定看起来几乎令人难以置信。是的。科尔特斯在欧洲是英雄吗？这是有趣的地方。即使在这一点上，说科尔特斯是一个非常、非常模棱两可，如果不是彻头彻尾令人讨厌的人物，也不是现代的“觉醒文化”。因为即使在当时，
I think there is an unease. I think Charles V, for example, would say that he is very uneasy with the idea of kind of rampaging in to somebody else's kingdom, toppling them and just taking it. Kings don't tend to like that kind of behavior. Right, because all the legalism that surrounds the narrative of Moctezuma handing over his empire to the king, I mean, who cares what the Mexica think among the Spaniards? It's about how they're presenting it to people back in Europe. Exactly. It needs to seem legal. Exactly. Exactly.
我认为也有一种不安。例如，查理五世会说，他对那种闯入别人的王国、推翻他们并直接占领的想法感到非常不安。国王们往往不喜欢那种行为。没错，因为围绕蒙特祖马将他的帝国移交给国王的叙事的所有法律主义，我的意思是，西班牙人中谁在乎墨西哥人怎么想？这是关于他们如何向欧洲的人们展示它。没错。它需要看起来合法。没错。没错。
It cannot just be a ruthless land grab. So even at this point in the early decades of European colonialism, there is a sense that just to barge in willy-nilly, kill everybody and take their lands is wrong. You have to have a legal pretext. And that's why there's all this fiction of Montezuma surrendering his kingdom and then the Aztecs being incited into this disgraceful rebellion. And also this is laying foundations for the sense that indigenous peoples do have rights to the lands that they inhabit, which will be woven into the international law that emerges in the 19th century. Yeah, absolutely. And by the way, jumping ahead of
它不能仅仅是一次无情的土地掠夺。所以即使在欧洲殖民主义的早期几十年里，也有这样一种感觉：仅仅是随心所欲地闯入、杀光所有人并夺取他们的土地是错误的。你必须有一个法律借口。这就是为什么会有蒙特祖马投降他的王国，然后阿兹特克人被煽动进行这种可耻叛乱的所有虚构。而且这也为原住民拥有他们所居住土地的权利奠定了基础，这些权利将被编织进 19 世纪出现的国际法中。是的，绝对是。顺便说一句，跳过我们自己，
ourselves, people like the Tlaxcalans, they are very jealous of those legal rights and their role as allies of the Spaniards. And they maintain it for many, many years to come, centuries to come, that they are self-governing. They have special privileges under the Spanish crown. And they do. Yeah.
像特拉斯卡拉人（Tlaxcalans）这样的人，他们非常珍视那些法律权利以及他们作为西班牙人盟友的角色。他们保持了这一点很多、很多年，几个世纪，他们是自治的。他们在西班牙王室下拥有特殊特权。他们确实有。是的。
And if they're ever challenged, they go to law. They go to court. They will send people to Spain to fight for their rights. And the Spanish will often acknowledge that. So the legalism is not just a fantasy or a fiction. It's real. Yeah. And that is the kind of the paradox of it, that the crimes of the conquistadors are judged by the same legal system that the Spanish are also bringing in. Yes, exactly. And that's another theme throughout European colonialism. It is. Absolutely, it is. On Cortés himself. Some of our very keenest listeners may remember
如果他们受到挑战，他们就会诉诸法律。他们会上法庭。他们会派人去西班牙为他们的权利而战。而西班牙人通常会承认这一点。所以法律主义不仅仅是幻想或虚构。它是真实的。是的。这就是它的悖论，征服者的罪行是由西班牙人也带来的同一法律体系来评判的。是的，没错。这也是整个欧洲殖民主义的一个主题。它是。绝对是。关于科尔特斯本人。我们一些最敏锐的听众可能记得
Cortés actually has a wife. I know. Since episode one. Cortés has a wife that Velázquez had forced him to marry on Cuba, Catalina Suárez. Now, she has been waiting all this time to find out what's going on with her husband, who's off in Mexico. She hears the news that he's won, and he doesn't call for her. And eventually,
科尔特斯实际上有一个妻子。我知道。从第一集开始。科尔特斯有一个妻子，贝拉斯克斯在古巴强迫他娶的，卡塔琳娜·苏亚雷斯（Catalina Suárez）。现在，她一直在等待，想知道她在墨西哥的丈夫发生了什么事。她听到他赢了的消息，但他没有叫她去。最终，
she runs out of patience, and she and her sister travel to Tenochtitlan themselves. And they get there late summer, early autumn. Oh, hello, darling. Exactly. Now, she is welcomed as a queen. People say, gosh, Cortes' wife, the wife of His Highness Cortes, the new master. Hurrah, hurrah for her. His mansion, the accounts that we have, Melinche gives birth to a little boy whom she christens, Martin Cortes. So that's kind of giving the game away a bit. And then something extraordinary happens. On All Saints Day, the 1st of November, Cortes holds a party at his house in Coyoacan. There's music and stuff, dancing and all this. And Cortes and Catalina
她失去了耐心，她和她的妹妹亲自前往特诺奇蒂特兰。她们在夏末秋初到达那里。哦，你好，亲爱的。没错。现在，她被当作女王欢迎。人们说，天哪，科尔特斯的妻子，科尔特斯殿下的妻子，新的主人。万岁，为她欢呼。他的豪宅，我们拥有的记录，马林切生下了一个小男孩，她给他起名为马丁·科尔特斯（Martin Cortes）。所以这有点泄露了秘密。然后发生了一件非凡的事情。在万圣节，11 月 1 日，科尔特斯在他科约阿坎的家中举行了一场派对。有音乐之类的，跳舞等等。而科尔特斯和卡塔琳娜
are seen quarreling or exchanging harsh words or something. And she goes to bed before him, and then he follows. And in the middle of the night, he wakes the house and he says, a terrible thing has happened. I found my wife dead in her room. She must have had a fit. I knew she had a very weak heart. What a terrible business. She must have accidentally thrown herself out of the window kind of thing. Exactly that. Very few people are allowed to see her body. She's buried in great haste. And from that point onwards, among the other Spaniards, there are rumours that he killed her, that he murdered her, he strangled her because she was in the way. Cramping his style.
被看到在争吵或交换严厉的话语之类的。她比他先上床睡觉，然后他跟着去了。半夜里，他叫醒了全家，他说，发生了一件可怕的事情。我发现我的妻子死在她的房间里。她一定发作了。我知道她心脏很弱。多么可怕的事情。她一定是意外地从窗户掉下去了之类的。正是那样。很少有人被允许看到她的尸体。她被匆忙埋葬。从那时起，在其他西班牙人中，有传言说他杀了她，他谋杀了她，他勒死了她，因为她挡了路。妨碍了他的生活方式。
Because he lost patience with her shouting at him about his mistresses. Who knows? And those rumours never, ever go away. And I don't think you have to be unduly harsh or censorious to think that that is part of a pattern with cortez he uses women and he dumps them and he dumps them and he is a brutal man but also the other thing must be that he has been in command for so long and he has been reaching out after what he wants for so long that the idea that he's going to pay attention to the strictures of anyone is a fantasy. Yes, I think that's absolutely right. Because conquering Tenochtitlan was the high point in his life and he doesn't really know what to do with himself, I think, afterwards. He clearly fancies himself as the master of Mexico.
因为他失去了耐心，她对他大喊大叫关于他的情妇。谁知道呢？而那些传言永远、永远不会消失。我不认为你必须过度严厉或吹毛求疵地认为那是科尔特斯模式的一部分，他利用女性，然后抛弃她们，他抛弃她们，他是一个残忍的人。但另一件事一定是，他掌权太久了，他追求他想要的东西太久了，以至于他会注意任何人的限制的想法是一个幻想。是的，我认为这绝对正确。因为征服特诺奇蒂特兰是他生命中的最高点，我认为他之后真的不知道该拿自己怎么办。他显然自认为是墨西哥的主人。
His original plan was to build himself an entirely new capital. So not far from Mexico City, there is an entirely new Spanish city So not far from Mexico City, there is an entirely new Spanish city called Puebla. Beautiful city, actually. It looks like a Spanish city. And that was their original plan. But eventually, Cortes clearly fancies the idea of becoming basically the new emperor of the Aztecs. So rebuilding Tenochtitlan and building a new city on the ruins of the old. And he will lay claim in inhabiting that city, he will lay claim to the prestige of Montezuma and his predecessors. And so what's impressive about this, and as you say, I mean, they're very beautiful, these buildings that are built in the earliest years
他最初的计划是为自己建造一个全新的首都。所以离墨西哥城不远，有一个全新的西班牙城市叫普埃布拉（Puebla）。实际上是一座美丽的城市。它看起来像一座西班牙城市。那是他们最初的计划。但最终，科尔特斯显然看中了成为阿兹特克人新皇帝的想法。所以重建特诺奇蒂特兰并在旧城的废墟上建造一座新城市。他将声称居住在那座城市，他将声称拥有蒙特祖马及其前任的威望。所以令人印象深刻的是，正如你所说，我的意思是，它们非常美丽，这些在西班牙征服的最初几年建造的建筑，
of the Spanish conquest, is that they must be built by Mexican workmen. Oh, they are. They absolutely are. I mean, so they adapt to the expectations of renaissance architecture very rapidly they do that's a very good point tom so cortez gets an architect from europe to design the new city a guy called alonso garcia bravo the plan is that basically it will be stratified on ethnic lines so the center will be spanish mansions for the conquistadors and the mexica will be confined to the outskirts. So again, another colonial theme being established.
它们一定是由墨西哥工人建造的。哦，它们是。它们绝对是。我的意思是，所以他们非常迅速地适应了文艺复兴建筑的期望，他们做到了。这是一个很好的观点，汤姆。所以科尔特斯从欧洲找来一位建筑师来设计这座新城市，一个叫阿隆索·加西亚·布拉沃（Alonso García Bravo）的人。计划基本上是按种族界限分层，所以中心将是为征服者准备的西班牙豪宅，而墨西哥人将被限制在郊区。所以，又一个殖民主题被确立了。
There you go. Yeah. They tear down the temples. They use the, I mean, could you get greater symbolism? They use the stones of the great temple to build the new cathedral in Mexico City, a cathedral which incidentally is currently sinking. So the cathedral in Mexico City is gradually collapsing, which is an extraordinary thing. They also use the stones to build a massive new palace is gradually collapsing, which is an extraordinary thing.
就是这样。是的。他们拆毁了寺庙。他们使用，我的意思是，你能找到更大的象征意义吗？他们用大寺庙的石头建造了墨西哥城的新大教堂，顺便说一句，这座大教堂目前正在下沉。所以墨西哥城的大教堂正在逐渐倒塌，这是一件非凡的事情。他们还用这些石头建造了一座巨大的新宫殿，正在逐渐倒塌，这是一件非凡的事情。
They also used the stones to build a massive new palace for Cortes, which still stands. It's in the center of the Zócalo in Mexico City. But as you say, Tom, the people who actually do the work are the Mexica, the Aztecs themselves. A visiting friar or monk said that he couldn't believe how enthusiastic they were. He said they seemed to be delighted by doing the work, and they were particularly fascinated by the Spanish building technology. So the carts and the wheelbarrows and the hammers and the chisels made of iron and all of these kinds of things. Well, this is one of the themes of Camilla Tansen's book, that actually the conquered don't just sit around and kind of gaze into the abyss, that they do pull themselves together. Yes.
他们还用这些石头为科尔特斯建造了一座巨大的新宫殿，它至今仍屹立不倒。它在墨西哥城的索卡洛（Zócalo）中心。但正如你所说，汤姆，实际干活的人是墨西哥人，阿兹特克人自己。一位来访的修士或僧侣说，他无法相信他们是多么热情。他说他们似乎对做这项工作感到高兴，而且他们对西班牙的建筑技术特别着迷。所以马车、独轮车、锤子和铁凿子以及所有这些东西。好吧，这是卡米拉·汤森书中的主题之一，实际上被征服者并不只是坐着，盯着深渊，他们确实振作了起来。是的。
They do say, well, you know, day will follow and night will follow. And so it goes on and they carry on living. They do. Because this monk says, there was such a great fervor that the laborers sang and their songs and their voices barely ceased at night. He's not going to make that up. No. I wouldn't have thought.
他们确实说，好吧，你知道，白天会过去，黑夜会过去。就这样继续下去，他们继续生活。他们确实。因为这位僧侣说，有如此巨大的热情，工人们唱歌，他们的歌声和声音在晚上几乎没有停止。他不会编造这个。不。我不会那样想。
So life does go on in a sense. The city ends up being renamed, of course, Ciudad de México, because the Spanish apparently struggle with the name Tenochtitlan, but also, of course, a new name. Yeah, a new start. Signals, a new era, though they use the word Mexica, México. But some of the cities follows the street plan of Tenochtitlan, actually. So you can sort of stand in places and think, you know, I'm standing now where the gate was. And there's a mural where Cortés and Montezuma are supposed to have met. And there are stretches, aren't there, of canals?
所以生活在某种意义上确实在继续。这座城市最终被重新命名，当然是墨西哥城（Ciudad de México），因为西班牙人显然对“特诺奇蒂特兰”这个名字感到吃力，但也当然，是一个新名字。是的，一个新的开始。标志着一个新时代，尽管他们使用了“墨西哥人”、“墨西哥”这个词。但有些城市遵循了特诺奇蒂特兰的街道规划，实际上。所以你可以站在某些地方想，你知道，我现在站在大门所在的地方。有一幅壁画，科尔特斯和蒙特祖马应该是在那里见面的。而且有运河的延伸，不是吗？
There are still some canals in the south of the city, exactly. Yeah. As for the rest of Mexico, the estates that belong to the Mexicas, the emperors and so on, they are parceled out. They're called encomiendas. Big estates in each encomienda is given to a different conquistador. The landscape itself is changing all the time, of course, because they are bringing over, as in the Caribbean, cows, pigs, sheep, all of these things, and new crops, things like olives and grapevines and things to grow in the new world. But the funny thing about this, you see, what makes it so ambiguous and so interesting is that the people who are working on these lands
在城市南部仍然有一些运河，完全正确。是的。至于墨西哥的其他地方，属于墨西哥人、皇帝等的庄园，它们被分割了。它们被称为“监护征赋制”（encomiendas）。每个监护征赋制中的大庄园被分给不同的征服者。景观本身一直在变化，当然，因为他们像在加勒比海一样，带来了牛、猪、羊，所有这些东西，以及新的作物，像橄榄、葡萄藤之类的东西，在新世界种植。但关于这一点有趣的事情是，你看，是什么让它如此模棱两可和有趣，那就是在这些土地上工作的人
are not slaves. They're more like peasants in feudal, medieval Europe. And actually, the question which Camilla Tantan's book, Fifth Son, really brings out is, how much do people notice that something has changed? Because up in the villages and away from the centers of habitation, life goes on. Yes, exactly. Exactly so. So, of course, they're also utterly ravaged by the smallpox. So for most people, I think this is probably the year of the smallpox rather than the Spaniards. If you're working in the fields, do you even see the Spaniards?
不是奴隶。他们更像是封建、中世纪欧洲的农民。实际上，卡米拉·汤森的书《第五个儿子》真正引出的问题是，人们注意到发生了什么变化有多少？因为在村庄里，远离居住中心，生活仍在继续。是的，完全正确。完全如此。所以，当然，他们也被天花彻底蹂躏了。所以对大多数人来说，我认为这可能是天花的一年，而不是西班牙人的一年。如果你在田里干活，你甚至能看到西班牙人吗？
You know, you're conscious that your tribute payments go to somebody different. And the Aztec aristocracy, it's not like the norman conquest they're not all decapitated the heirs of moctezuma i mean this is why they buy into the idea that moctezuma had submitted to the spanish it's because it gives them a claim you know that they can then use in spanish law courts to keep hold of their lands they do it very successfully because they end up being treated with respect. The Spanish are very, very deferential towards rank and legalism and hierarchy and all these kinds of things. But you have to convert to Christianity to get that. If you convert to Christianity, if you say, God, I love Charles V. I can't get enough of Charles V. I'm so delighted to be living in this new Spanish imperium. If you do all these things, then you can have your own
你知道，你意识到你的贡品支付给了不同的人。而阿兹特克贵族，这不像诺曼征服，他们并没有全部被斩首。蒙特祖马的继承人，我的意思是，这就是为什么他们接受蒙特祖马已经向西班牙人投降的想法，因为这给了他们一个主张，你知道，他们随后可以在西班牙法庭上使用它来保住他们的土地。他们做得非常成功，因为他们最终受到了尊重。西班牙人对等级、法律主义和等级制度以及所有这些东西非常、非常恭敬。但你必须皈依基督教才能得到那个。如果你皈依基督教，如果你说，上帝，我爱查理五世。我怎么也爱不够查理五世。我很高兴能生活在这个新的西班牙帝国里。如果你做所有这些事情，那么你就可以拥有你自己的
estate. You can prosper. You can go to Madrid and sue the king for your historic privileges and all those kinds of things. I mean, of course, that's not to say it's sweetness and light and there's not all kinds of exploitation and violence. Well, Matthew Restles, the final chapter in his book on Moctezuma meeting with Cortes gives a terrifying portrait of it. I mean, it's like the kind of Nazi occupation of Poland, mass rape, slaughter. How would you square his portrayal of the horrors of it? With Camilla Townsend's. I mean, Camilla Townsend is saying that people, they live lives as they must do. But I have also read accounts that say that actually there are whole reaches of Mexico where the Spanish barely reach,
庄园。你可以繁荣。你可以去马德里起诉国王以获得你的历史特权以及所有那些事情。我的意思是，当然，这并不是说它是甜蜜和光明的，没有各种剥削和暴力。好吧，马修·雷斯特尔在他关于蒙特祖马会见科尔特斯的书的最后一章中给出了一个可怕的写照。我的意思是，这就像纳粹占领波兰，大规模强奸、屠杀。你如何将他对恐怖的描绘与卡米拉·汤森的描绘相协调？我的意思是，卡米拉·汤森说人们，他们过着他们必须过的生活。但我还读到过一些记录，说实际上墨西哥有整个区域西班牙人几乎没有到达，
where people continue to worship the old gods. Which is certainly true. It would come as news that Tenochtitlan had fallen. Yeah. So, I mean, if you're in the eye of the storm, then it's terrible, but equally, you know, it could just completely pass you by. I think it's a very complicated picture, Tom. And actually, to impose one verdict on the whole thing is wrong. Because, of course, there are some places, I mean, Tlaxcala most obviously.
人们继续崇拜旧神。这当然是真的。特诺奇蒂特兰已经陷落的消息对他们来说将是新闻。是的。所以，我的意思是，如果你在风暴眼中，那么它是可怕的，但同样，你知道，它可能完全与你擦肩而过。我认为这是一个非常复杂的情况，汤姆。实际上，对整件事强加一个判决是错误的。因为，当然，有一些地方，我的意思是，特拉斯卡拉最明显。
Effectively, it's a republic under the King of Spain. Tlaxcala's are left alone. Europeans are not allowed to settle in Tlaxcala. They've done brilliantly out of this. They've defeated their age-old enemies. They now have a new imperial overlord in the King of Spain, but the King of Spain regards them with affection because they're his allies. So as far as they're concerned, great.
实际上，它是西班牙国王下的一个共和国。特拉斯卡拉人被留下了。欧洲人不允许在特拉斯卡拉定居。他们从中做得非常出色。他们击败了他们古老的敌人。他们现在在西班牙国王那里有了一个新的帝国霸主，但西班牙国王对他们怀有感情，因为他们是他的盟友。所以就他们而言，太棒了。
Anything but the Mexica. If you're one of the Mexica or their allies, life is terrible and you are subject to the violence of the conquistadors. Your family could have been sold into slavery, all of these things. Awful. But if you're in an outlying region, and particularly the further away from Tenochtitlan you are,
除了墨西哥人以外，什么都行。如果你是墨西哥人或他们的盟友之一，生活是可怕的，你受到征服者暴力的支配。你的家人可能被卖为奴隶，所有这些事情。糟糕。但如果你在一个偏远地区，特别是离特诺奇蒂特兰越远，
and the more rural, the more difficult to reach, the chances are you could live your life and never lay eyes on a Spaniard, I would guess. And of course, in some of these parts, those are really difficult to reach. In the Yucatan, for example, I mean, there... They still supposedly worship Tlaloc to this day, apparently. I don't know if that's true or not. I mean, there are parts that are not even nominally conquered until the end of the 17th century. So the idea that the conquest of Mexico is done and dusted by the early 1520s is obviously completely wrong.
而且越偏远，越难到达，我猜你很有可能过完一生而从未见过西班牙人。当然，在其中一些地方，那些真的很难到达。例如在尤卡坦半岛，我的意思是，那里……他们据说至今仍崇拜特拉洛克（Tlaloc），显然。我不知道那是不是真的。我的意思是，有些部分直到 17 世纪末才名义上被征服。所以认为墨西哥的征服在 1520 年代初就完成了，显然是完全错误的。
And Dominic, one other thing that happens within, what, a decade of the fall of Tenochtitlan is that the Virgin Mary appears to a peasant. Oh, right. Yes. I thought we'd get onto that. And speaks to him in Nahuatl. Yes. So that's the Virgin of Guadalupe, who supposedly appears to a guy called Juan Diego,
多米尼克，在特诺奇蒂特兰陷落后的十年内发生的另一件事是，圣母玛利亚向一位农民显现。哦，对。是的。我以为我们会谈到那个。并用纳瓦特尔语对他说话。是的。所以那是瓜达卢佩圣母（Virgin of Guadalupe），她据说向一个叫胡安·迭戈（Juan Diego）的人显现，
who gets a sort of image imprinted on his cloak. What is so interesting about that story, Tom, is first of all, it probably didn't happen because the accounts that we have come are later and it's probably been kind of back projected. And secondly, the place where that happens, which is a hill called Tepeac, which is north of Lake Texcoco, was already a pilgrimage site. I think this is a really interesting element of the story. So it had been sacred to the Aztec goddesses Tonantzin and Chico Mecoatl, who are the goddesses of the earth and a farming kind of fertility.
他的斗篷上印上了一种形象。那个故事最有趣的地方，汤姆，首先是它可能没有发生，因为我们拥有的记录是后来的，它可能被某种程度上倒推了。其次，发生这件事的地方，也就是特佩亚克（Tepeyac）的一座山，在特斯科科湖（Lake Texcoco）以北，已经是一个朝圣地。我认为这是故事中一个非常有趣的元素。所以它对阿兹特克女神托南辛（Tonantzin）和奇科梅科亚特尔（Chico Mecoatl）来说是神圣的，她们是大地和农业生育的女神。
So very like the way that the Parthenon, the temple to Athena, becomes a church dedicated to the Virgin. Exactly. So when people are going to this shrine, the shrine of the Virgin of Guadalupe, they are not necessarily completely breaking with the shrine of the Virgin of Guadalupe, they are not necessarily completely breaking with the traditions of their ancestors. They're actually going to the same place their ancestors might well have gone to. But also, the Virgin weeps over the sufferings of her dead son. I wonder if that is a way in for people to this new
所以非常像帕台农神庙，雅典娜的神庙，变成了一座献给圣母的教堂的方式。没错。所以当人们去这个圣地，瓜达卢佩圣母的圣地时，他们不一定完全与他们祖先的传统决裂。他们实际上去了他们祖先很可能去过的同一个地方。但圣母也为她死去的儿子的苦难而哭泣。我想知道这是否是人们进入这种对超自然现象的新理解的一种方式。是的。不，汤姆，关于宗教元素，我知道你显然觉得宗教元素很迷人，这是可以理解的。我的意思是，这是席卷他们所称的“新西班牙”，即后来的墨西哥的所有变化中最明显的一个。但即便如此，它也非常复杂，因为它非常融合，不是吗？到达墨西哥的修士们说，好吧，我们必须为这些人做出让步。我们必须允许他们保持他们的一些旧习俗。例如，他们非常乐意允许墨西哥原住民在像他们旧寺庙一样的露天教堂里礼拜。而雕刻这些东西的石匠们确实使用了旧的祭祀石来建造祭坛之类的东西。我只是想知道关于苦难和失败者的故事，苦难，是的，
understanding of the supernatural. Yeah. No, Tom, on the religious element, I know the religious element you obviously find fascinating and understandably so. I mean, this is the most obvious of all the changes that sweeps over what they call New Spain, what becomes Mexico. But even then, it's so complicated because it's quite syncretic, isn't it? The friars who arrive in Mexico, they say, well, we've got to make allowances for these people. We've got to allow them to keep up some of their old customs. So for example, they're very happy to allow the indigenous Mexican people to worship in open-air chapels that are like their old temples. And the stonemasons who carve the things in the true that they use the old sacrificial stones to build altars and things i just wonder whether the story of suffering and the underdog the suffering yes and
和复活，因为死而复生的想法是支撑希佩托特克（Xipe Totec）崇拜的基础，你知道，穿着剥下的皮游荡可能看起来离耶稣受难日很远，但那里确实有一种从最凄凉的绝望中涌现出希望的叙事，也许确实能触动人们。我的意思是，墨西哥最终确实成为了一个非常天主教的国家。它确实。我不知道。我对它了解不够。汤姆，我认为这非常可信，但其中还有另一个因素，当然，基督教是赢家的宗教。
resurrection because the idea of life coming from the dead is what underpins the cult of chippy totech you know wandering in flayed skins might seem a long way from Good Friday, but there is a kind of narrative there of hope emerging from the bleakest despair that perhaps does speak to people. I mean, Mexico does end up a very Catholic country. It does. I don't know. I don't know enough about it. Tom, I think that's very plausible, but there's another element to it, which is, of course, Christianity is the religion of the winners.
是的，当然。我的意思是，这绝对是不言而喻的，但基督教一直是一个悖论。你知道，它是赢家的宗教。它是全世界实践最广泛的宗教。但与此同时，它为那些受苦的人，那些，你知道，被折磨或迫害的人，提供了一种与神圣认同的特殊感。无论如何，听着，多米尼克，我们在这里休息一下。当我们回来时，也许我们可以看看这个故事中的一些主角发生了什么。然后，你知道，只是稍微思考一下这个剧集在世界历史背景下以及也许在当今政治背景下的地位。非常好。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持《历史的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。
Yes, of course. I mean, that absolutely goes without saying, but it has always been a paradox, Christianity. You know, it is the religion of the winners. It's the most practiced religion across the world. But at the same time, it offers a peculiar sense of identification with the divine to those who have suffered, those who have, you know, been tortured or persecuted. Anyway, listen, Dominic, let's take a break here. And when we come back, perhaps we could look at what happens to some of the protagonists in this story. And then, you know, just kind of have a brief think about what exactly the status of this episode is in the context of world history and perhaps of the politics today. Very good. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。com 你好，欢迎回到我们关于阿兹特克陨落的八集史诗的最后一部分，多米尼克，我们在上一部分的结尾说我们将看看这个故事中的一些主角发生了什么，所以首先是科尔特斯，这个故事中的一些主角发生了什么。所以首先是科尔特斯，科尔特斯发生了什么？好吧，在我们做那个之前，汤姆，最后一件事。如果还有人在听，如果你坚持到了最后，恭喜你，你是最坚韧的坚韧者。《历史的余味》爱好者。做得好。谢谢你们收听到现在，因为我不认为，
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. dot com hello welcome back to the last segment of our eight part epic on the fall of the aztecs and dominic we said at the end of the previous part that we would look at what happens to some of the protagonists in this story so first of all cortez what happens to some of the protagonists in this story. So first of all, Cortez, what happens to Cortez? Well, before we do that, Tom, just one last thing. If anybody is still listening, if you've made it through, congratulations, you are the hardiest of the hard. Rest is history, aficionados. Well done. And thank you for listening so far, because I don't think,
这是您每周的娱乐新闻、评论和演艺圈八卦资讯，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的幕后，为您讲述其运作方式。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想享受无广告收听、额外剧集以及提前购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到我们关于阿兹特克帝国覆灭的八集史诗系列的最后一部分。多米尼克，我们在上一部分的结尾说过，我们要看看这个故事中一些主角的结局。那么首先，科尔特斯，这个故事中的一些主角后来怎么样了？首先，科尔特斯，科尔特斯后来怎么样了？嗯，汤姆，在我们开始之前，还有最后一件事。如果还有人在听，如果你坚持到了现在，恭喜你，你是最坚韧不拔的听众。历史余韵的爱好者们，做得好。感谢你们一直以来的收听，因为我不认为，
Tom, we've ever done anything in this detail. So Cortez, the story of Cortez is the story of all conquistadors really. They all just fall out with each other once they've won and everything is very miserable. And they generally prove not to be as good at governing as they are at conquering. I mean, all he's ever been is a sort of low rent notary. So why would he be the great kind of chief executive of a state? Of course he wouldn't. If you don't like the conquistadors, you'll be pleased to hear that most of the conquistadors come to relatively sticky ends or die in obscurity or die poor because they've been sued by each other or they've been in some way punished by the Spanish crown or whatever. In Cortes' case, Cortes is there in Mexico City. And in 1524, he sends one of his most trusted
汤姆，我们以前从未如此详细地做过任何事情。所以科尔特斯，科尔特斯的故事实际上就是所有征服者的故事。他们一旦获胜，彼此之间就会闹翻，一切都变得非常悲惨。而且他们通常证明自己在治理方面并不像在征服方面那样出色。我的意思是，他一直以来不过是一个低级的公证人。那么他为什么会成为一个国家伟大的首席执行官呢？当然不会。如果你不喜欢征服者，你会很高兴听到大多数征服者的下场都相对凄惨，或者默默无闻地死去，或者因为被彼此起诉，或者以某种方式受到西班牙王室的惩罚等等而贫困潦倒。就科尔特斯而言，他当时在墨西哥城。1524年，他派出了他最信任的
allies, one of his most trusted captains, a guy called Cristobal de Olid, off with 500 men to Honduras in the south, because they've heard that Central America is the place for gold. Still this thirst for gold. In absolutely classic conquistador fashion, Cristobal de Olid stops on his way in Cuba, where he meets their old friend, Diego Velasquez, and agrees to do a deal with him and to sell out Cortes and to establish a separate principality in Honduras. Cortes goes absolutely mad when he hears this, and he decides to pursue Ollid down to Honduras. Now, Cortes thinks of himself as a very grand man these days, so he takes a huge company with him. 3,000 native troops, Tom, a chamberlain, a steward, a butler, a waiter,
盟友之一，他最信任的队长之一，一个叫克里斯托瓦尔·德·奥利德的人，带着500人前往南部的洪都拉斯，因为他们听说中美洲是黄金之地。依然是对黄金的渴望。以绝对经典的征服者方式，克里斯托瓦尔·德·奥利德在前往古巴的途中停了下来，在那里他遇到了他们的老朋友迭戈·委拉斯开兹，并同意与他达成协议，背叛科尔特斯，并在洪都拉斯建立一个独立的公国。科尔特斯听到这个消息后简直疯了，他决定追赶奥利德到洪都拉斯。现在，科尔特斯这些天把自己看作一个非常伟大的人，所以他带了一大群人。3000名土著士兵，汤姆，一个管家，一个总管，一个男仆，一个侍者，
eight footmen, several jugglers, and a musical band. You wouldn't want to travel anywhere without jugglers. Well, thank God there were no Mayim artists. If the French had got there first, Tom, rather than the Spanish. Well, Mayim artists have played an important part, haven't they, in the early stages of the story, because it was the only way for the Spanish to communicate with the Native Americans. Exactly. Now, he takes Melinche with him, by by the way and it's on this trip that they pass her old native village the place where she'd been born all those years before coatzacoalcos and he gives her her native village as her own estate her own encomienda and also cortez who
八个随从，几个杂耍艺人，还有一个乐队。你可不想在没有杂耍艺人的情况下到处旅行。好吧，谢天谢地，没有哑剧演员。如果法国人先到那里，汤姆，而不是西班牙人。嗯，哑剧演员在故事的早期阶段发挥了重要作用，不是吗？因为这是西班牙人与美洲原住民交流的唯一方式。没错。现在，顺便说一句，他带着马林切一起，正是在这次旅行中，他们经过了她多年前出生的老家夸察夸尔科斯，他把她的家乡作为她自己的庄园，她自己的监护征赋制，而且科尔特斯，他
is the father of her son he says i will marry you to one of my comrades a guy called juan jaramillo so that she will become a Spanish. So you are now Spanish. Have Spanish legal rights. You have Spanish rights and your child will have Spanish rights. You know, you might think, well, who wants to be married to some nobody? But actually, this is a big deal for Malinche. Yeah, it's kind of green card.
是她儿子的父亲，他说我将把你嫁给我的一位同志，一个叫胡安·哈拉米略的人，这样她就会成为西班牙人。所以你现在是西班牙人了。拥有西班牙的法律权利。你拥有西班牙的权利，你的孩子也将拥有西班牙的权利。你知道，你可能会想，谁想嫁给一个无名小卒呢？但实际上，这对马林切来说是一件大事。是的，这就像绿卡。
He crucially also on this expedition to Honduras, Tom, he takes the last emperor of Mexico with him. He takes Cuauhtémoc. So his feet must be, he's had them burned. He has with his burned feet. He goes. So, I mean, can he walk? I can't imagine he can walk if he's had his feet burned. I don't know. Has he been carried in a litter or something? Yeah, or trudging or on horseback.
汤姆，他在这次前往洪都拉斯的远征中，至关重要的是他还带上了墨西哥的最后一位皇帝。他带上了夸特莫克。所以他的脚一定，他的脚被烧伤了。他带着烧伤的脚。他去了。所以，我的意思是，他能走路吗？我无法想象如果他的脚被烧伤了他还能走路。我不知道。他是被担架抬着还是什么的？是的，或者蹒跚而行，或者骑马。
You can't trudge if you've had your feet burned. This is a very good question, Tom. Sometimes when the rest is history, we just have to admit that we don't know. And this is something that I don't. I mean, is he on crutches? Who knows? Okay. All right.
如果你的脚被烧伤了，你就不能蹒跚而行。这是一个非常好的问题，汤姆。有时当历史成为过去时，我们只能承认我们不知道。这是我不知道的事情。我的意思是，他是拄着拐杖吗？谁知道呢？好吧。好吧。
It's a horrible situation for him. They get there and they get stuck basically in the jungles of southern Mexico. They're going very, very slowly. It's incredibly hot and humid. This is your classic kind of leeches. Eldorado kind of. Eldorado sinking into bogs, kind of weird beasts
对他来说这是一个可怕的情况。他们到达那里，基本上被困在墨西哥南部的丛林中。他们走得非常非常慢。天气非常炎热潮湿。这是你经典的某种水蛭。黄金国那种。黄金国陷入沼泽，某种奇怪的野兽
baying in the night. That kind of... Snakes coiling in the branches overhead. This is exactly what happens. And at some point in late February 1525, there's a very garbled,
在夜里嚎叫。那种……蛇在头顶的树枝上盘绕。这正是发生的事情。在1525年2月下旬的某个时候，发生了一件非常混乱、
confused incident. What sources there are utterly contradict each other and it's impossible to tell what's going on. Somebody, we don't know who, could be one of the mexica it could be a local maya could be a spaniard they come to cortez and they say there's a plot to kill you to assassinate you on this trip and actually cuartemoc and the other aztec nobles are behind it is this real is this just a pretext we don't know has he gone mad exactly basically the upshot is the spaniards
模糊的事件。现有的资料完全相互矛盾，根本无法判断发生了什么。有人，我们不知道是谁，可能是墨西哥人之一，可能是当地的玛雅人，可能是西班牙人，他们来到科尔特斯面前说，这次旅行中有一个杀你的阴谋，要暗杀你，实际上夸特莫克和其他阿兹特克贵族是幕后黑手，这是真的吗？这只是一个借口吗？我们不知道，他疯了吗？基本上结果是西班牙人
get cuauhtemoc and they hang him from a tree and that's the end of him and bernal diaz who is there yet again he gives him a final speech to cortez in his final words cuauhtemoc is still addressing cortez as melince and he says to him apparently oh melince now i understand your false promises and the kind of death you've had in store for me. You're killing me unjustly. May God demand justice from you as it was taken from me when I entrusted myself to you in my city of Mexico. Well, I mean, if he's misgendering, Cortez. Well, yes. He deserves all he gets. Do you know what happens to his body? I don't actually. Do you? No. Maybe it's still there. Should we do some live research on the Bodleian?
抓住了夸特莫克，把他吊在树上，这就是他的结局，而当时也在场的贝尔纳尔·迪亚斯再次记录了他对科尔特斯的最后演讲，在最后的遗言中，夸特莫克仍然称呼科尔特斯为马林切，他显然对他说，哦，马林切，现在我明白了你的虚假承诺和你为我准备的死亡方式。你正在不公正地杀害我。愿上帝向你索取正义，就像我在墨西哥城托付给你时从我这里夺走的一样。好吧，我的意思是，如果他称呼科尔特斯为女性。好吧，是的。他罪有应得。你知道他的尸体发生了什么吗？我其实不知道。你知道吗？不。也许它还在那里。我们应该对博德利图书馆做一些实时研究吗？
If you want to, Tom. Okay. So this is live research on the Bodleian. The modern-day town of Excateopan in the state of Guerrero is home to an ossuary purportedly containing his remains. Oh, but that word purportedly, Tom, is a bit of a... An archaeologist who was a passionate indigenista excavated the bones in 1949. Theo has put in the chat, that's exactly where I thought it was. I don't believe that Theo is telling the truth there.
如果你想的话，汤姆。好吧。这是对博德利图书馆的实时研究。格雷罗州的埃斯卡特奥潘镇是据称存放他遗骸的藏骨堂所在地。哦，但是那个词“据称”，汤姆，有点……一位热情的本土主义考古学家在1949年挖掘了这些骨头。西奥在聊天中说，那正是我想象的地方。我不相信西奥在那里说的是实话。
I think that's yet another unreliable source. A scholarly study of the controversy was published in 2011 and argued that the available data suggests that the grave is an elaborate hoax. Oh no, Tom. Compared by local as a way of generating publicity. Well. And that subsequently supported by Mexican nationalists who wished to use the find for political purposes.
我认为那是另一个不可靠的消息来源。2011年发表的一项关于这场争议的学术研究认为，现有数据表明这座坟墓是一个精心策划的骗局。哦，不，汤姆。被当地人比作一种制造宣传的方式。好吧。随后被希望利用这一发现达到政治目的的墨西哥民族主义者所支持。
So I can't believe that they would have allowed his remains. No, I think it's unlikely. Right, so that's the end of Cuauhtémoc. The trip to Honduras, it turned out, was a total and utter waste of time. Olid had already been captured and executed by somebody else. So Cortés then troops very miserably back to Mexico City. Of his original party that set out of 4,000 people, there were just a few hundred left,
所以我无法相信他们会允许他的遗骸。不，我认为这不太可能。好吧，这就是夸特莫克的结局。事实证明，前往洪都拉斯的旅行完全是浪费时间。奥利德已经被别人抓获并处决了。所以科尔特斯非常悲惨地回到了墨西哥城。在他出发时的原始队伍中，有4000人，只剩下几百人了，
absolutely standard kind of conquistador jungle expedition. They've all been killed by hunger or disease. Malinche not killed. She goes on to have another daughter called Maria. But once she gets back to Mexico City after this trip, that is the last we ever see of her. It's generally thought that she probably died at the end of the 1520s. So how old would she have been then? Early 20s, I suppose? Something like that. Late 20s. Yeah. Something like that, Tom. We don't even know when she was born, you see. We don't have much of a sense of her age even. There's a house in Mexico City. I went to look at it earlier this year, 95 Republica de Cuba Street. And it's a very dilapidated looking house, actually. And it's claimed, almost certainly erroneously,
绝对是标准的征服者丛林远征。他们都被饥饿或疾病杀死了。马林切没有死。她后来又生了一个女儿叫玛丽亚。但当她这次旅行后回到墨西哥城，那是我们最后一次见到她。人们普遍认为她可能死于1520年代末。那么她那时多大年纪？我想是20多岁出头？差不多吧。20多岁末。是的。差不多，汤姆。你看，我们甚至不知道她是什么时候出生的。我们甚至对她的年龄没有太多概念。墨西哥城有一所房子。我今年早些时候去看过，古巴共和国街95号。实际上，那是一所看起来非常破旧的房子。而且有人声称，几乎可以肯定是错误的，
that this is where she lived in Mexico City. And people say, if you go there after nightfall, you can hear a ghost crying. I wonder what she's crying over. Well. Guilt, bereavement, regret. Yeah, I don't know. I didn't hear the ghost, so I can't answer that question.
这就是她在墨西哥城住的地方。人们说，如果你在天黑后去那里，你可以听到一个鬼魂在哭泣。我想知道她在为什么哭。好吧。内疚、丧亲、遗憾。是的，我不知道。我没有听到鬼魂，所以我无法回答那个问题。
Have we got any listeners who've heard the ghost of Malinche sobbing and have some sense of what it's about? Yeah. Cortez gets back to Mexico City and for such a cunning man, he's made an absolute schoolboy error. If you're a conquistador, you never leave your base because if you leave your base once you've got it, somebody else will take it from you. And he arrives back in Mexico City to find it in total chaos. People are arguing about who's in charge. He's also in a mess
我们有听众听到过马林切的鬼魂在啜泣，并对它是什么原因有所了解吗？是的。科尔特斯回到墨西哥城，对于这样一个精明的人来说，他犯了一个绝对是小学生水平的错误。如果你是一个征服者，你永远不要离开你的基地，因为如果你一旦拥有了基地却离开它，别人就会把它从你手中夺走。他回到墨西哥城，发现那里一片混乱。人们在争论谁负责。他也陷入了困境
because Diego Velazquez has never forgiven him. And for the rest of his life, he is beset by lawsuits and legal cases and accusations being made by Velazquistas saying that Cortes is corrupt. Cortes is taking bribes. Cortes is not ruling justly. So he's the first European leader on the North American continent to find himself harassed by lawsuits. Exactly. But not the last. But not very good, Tom.
因为迭戈·委拉斯开兹从未原谅过他。在他余生中，他一直受到诉讼、法律案件和委拉斯开兹派的指控，称科尔特斯腐败。科尔特斯在收受贿赂。科尔特斯统治不公正。所以他是北美大陆上第一个发现自己被诉讼骚扰的欧洲领导人。没错。但不是最后一个。但不太好，汤姆。
So he basically spends the rest of his life between Spain and Mexico. He ends up losing the title of governor. So this is very Columbus, isn't it? It's the same arc. It's very Columbus. It's very Columbus. He tries another expedition, again, very Columbus, where he goes up to California. He goes up to Baja California and he lands there and he doesn't find anything worthwhile.
所以他基本上余生都在西班牙和墨西哥之间度过。他最终失去了总督的头衔。所以这非常像哥伦布，不是吗？这是同样的弧线。这非常像哥伦布。这非常像哥伦布。他尝试了另一次远征，同样非常像哥伦布，他去了加利福尼亚。他去了下加利福尼亚，他在那里登陆，但没有发现任何有价值的东西。
He ends up back in Spain by the 1540s, a completely obscure, forgotten man living in an estate near Seville. And he dies in Seville in 1547. He's not a big celebrity by then. It's not like Hernan Cortes has died, one of the great figures of the age. Gosh, what a moment in history. It's actually, he's forgotten by them. It's not like Hernan Cortes has died, one of the great figures of the age, gosh, what a moment in history. It's actually, he's forgotten by now. But books about him are coming out, aren't they? They are, but people are ambivalent about him even then. There's a sense of him,
到1540年代，他最终回到了西班牙，成了一个完全默默无闻、被遗忘的人，住在塞维利亚附近的一个庄园里。他于1547年在塞维利亚去世。那时他不是什么大名人。不像埃尔南·科尔特斯去世了，那个时代最伟大的人物之一。天哪，历史上的一个时刻。实际上，他那时被遗忘了。不像埃尔南·科尔特斯去世了，那个时代最伟大的人物之一，天哪，历史上的一个时刻。实际上，他现在被遗忘了。但是关于他的书正在出版，不是吗？是的，但即使在那个时候，人们对他也是矛盾的。有一种感觉，
to some, he's a hero. What's his name? Gamara. Gamara, his former secretary, has written this memoir. I mean, he just writes a kind of mad hagiography. Total hagiography. And even then, there are a lot of people who say it is a hagiography. Cortés has a lot of enemies. His body ends up being taken back to Mexico City. So again, this is very Columbus. And his bones are currently in the chapel of the Hospital de Jesus Nazareno, which supposedly he founded, the Hospital of Jesus of Nazareth,
对一些人来说，他是英雄。他叫什么名字？加马拉。加马拉，他以前的秘书，写了这本回忆录。我的意思是，他只是写了一种疯狂的圣徒传。完全的圣徒传。即使在那个时候，也有很多人说这是一部圣徒传。科尔特斯有很多敌人。他的尸体最终被带回了墨西哥城。所以这再次非常像哥伦布。他的骨头目前在拿撒勒耶稣医院的礼拜堂里，据说是他建立的，拿撒勒耶稣医院，
which is near the spot, so people say, where he first met Montezuma on the causeway. But of course, Cortes is very much without honor in Mexico. In Spain, he is well regarded. There's a statue of him in Medellin. He was on a Spanish banknote as recently as 1992. Wow. So the fateful year. Yeah, of course. The anniversary of Columbus. But if you look for sort of traces of him in Mexico, Tom, they're all incredibly unflattering. They are, you know, murals showing him as a monster. The Diego Rivera one showing him as a knock-kneed green syphilitic. Exactly.
就在人们所说的他在堤道上第一次见到蒙特祖马的地方附近。但当然，科尔特斯在墨西哥非常没有荣誉。在西班牙，他受到高度评价。在麦德林有一座他的雕像。早在1992年，他就出现在西班牙的钞票上。哇。所以那个决定性的年份。是的，当然。哥伦布的周年纪念日。但如果你在墨西哥寻找他的踪迹，汤姆，它们都非常不讨人喜欢。它们是，你知道，壁画显示他是一个怪物。迭戈·里维拉的那幅画显示他是一个膝盖内扣、患有梅毒的绿色怪物。没错。
Exactly. All of that stuff. Books about him as a war criminal and all this kind of stuff. And actually, there are kind of, you know, neighborhoods of Mexico City named after some of the Mexica protagonists. So for example, Cuauhtémoc, but there's no Aynan Cortez unless I'm mistaken. So Cuauhtémoc is, I mean, he can be presented as a martyr. Absolutely, he can. And, you know, we're talking about what happens to his bones and the desire to manufacture it. I mean, he is of appeal to nationalists. Yes, yes. He's an inspirational figure to indigenous Mexicans
没错。所有这些东西。关于他是战犯的书，所有这些东西。实际上，墨西哥城有一些街区是以一些墨西哥主角的名字命名的。例如，夸特莫克，但没有埃尔南·科尔特斯，除非我弄错了。所以夸特莫克是，我的意思是，他可以被塑造成一个烈士。绝对可以。而且，你知道，我们正在谈论他的骨头发生了什么以及制造它的愿望。我的意思是，他对民族主义者有吸引力。是的，是的。他是土著墨西哥人的鼓舞人心的形象
because he held out to the last. He never surrendered. He never told the Spanish there was all this hidden gold. He smiled when they burned his feet. He gave a defiant speech when they were executing him. He's a formidable person. In a weird way, I think his reputation is higher than Montezuma's. Actually, not a weird way at all.
因为他坚持到了最后。他从未投降。他从未告诉西班牙人有所有这些隐藏的黄金。当他们烧伤他的脚时，他微笑了。当他们处决他时，他发表了挑衅性的演讲。他是一个令人生畏的人。以一种奇怪的方式，我认为他的声誉比蒙特祖马高。实际上，一点也不奇怪。
Not a weird way at all. I mean, Montezuma is despised, isn't he? I think very harshly. Yes, I agree harshly. As for the other protagonists, just before we talk about the ramifications of the story, Diego Balazquez, who basically was the guy who wanted New Spain for himself, he dies in his bed in the 1520s. So he dies by conquistador standards.
一点也不奇怪。我的意思是，蒙特祖马被鄙视，不是吗？我认为非常严厉。是的，我同意严厉。至于其他主角，在我们谈论故事的后果之前，迭戈·巴拉斯克斯，他基本上是那个想为自己占有新西班牙的人，他在1520年代死在床上。所以他按照征服者的标准去世了。
Not such a bad ending. Panfilo de Narvaez, you described him as that wildling from Game of Thrones, Tom, with the big red beard. The guy pitched up, Cortes gouged out his eye on the coast. He leads an absolutely ridiculous expedition, even by conquistador standards, where they go up to Florida again. They end up being attacked by Native Americans in Florida. They end up building boats and going across the southern shore of the United States towards Texas. And he ends up being drowned in Galveston, Texas.
结局不算太坏。潘菲洛·德·纳尔瓦埃斯，你把他描述为《权力的游戏》里的那个野人，汤姆，留着大红胡子。那个家伙闯了进来，科尔特斯在海岸上挖出了他的眼睛。他领导了一次绝对荒谬的远征，即使按照征服者的标准，他们再次前往佛罗里达。他们最终在佛罗里达受到美洲原住民的攻击。他们最终建造船只，穿过美国南部海岸前往德克萨斯。他最终在德克萨斯的加尔维斯顿淹死了。
And the rest of his expedition, this is the very famous Cabezo de Vaca expedition, they end up as slaves in Texas and they end up walking 2,000 miles home to Mexico City. One of those bonkers stories of the conquistadors.
而他远征的其余部分，这就是非常著名的卡贝萨·德·瓦卡远征，他们最终在德克萨斯沦为奴隶，并最终步行2000英里回到墨西哥城。征服者那些疯狂的故事之一。
Pedro de Alvarado in his gilet, you know, very much a kind of- Lads on tour member of the university rugby club yeah theo's just written lad in the chat but a very violent one he kind of rampages randomly across the kind of highlands of central america guatemala honduras el salvador trying to carve out his own kingdom he tries to get involved with the conquest of the incas but he arrives too late and actually people who think he sounds like a terrible person would be pleased to hear he comes to a very pathetic end. He gets crushed beneath a boulder or something, doesn't he?
佩德罗·德·阿尔瓦拉多穿着他的背心，你知道，非常像一个——大学橄榄球队的旅游成员，是的，西奥刚才在聊天中写了“小伙子”，但一个非常暴力的。他在中美洲、危地马拉、洪都拉斯、萨尔瓦多的高地上随机横冲直撞，试图开辟自己的王国。他试图参与印加人的征服，但他到达得太晚了，实际上那些认为他听起来像个可怕的人会很高兴听到他有一个非常可悲的结局。他被一块巨石压在下面，不是吗？
A combination of horse and boulder. So he agrees to help a friend put down a revolt, they say revolt in inverted commas, in Zacatecas, which is in central Mexico. And his horse slips on the hillside and falls on top of him. And apparently at that point, then a boulder rolls down the hill and crushes him to death. It seems unlikely that the boulder would, it's just a coincidence, the boulder would also roll. Anyway, I'm not going to dig into that story too. He ends up flat. Yeah.
马和巨石的结合。所以他同意帮助一个朋友平息一场叛乱，他们说叛乱加了引号，在萨卡特卡斯，那是在墨西哥中部。他的马在山坡上滑倒，压在他身上。显然在那一刻，一块巨石滚下山坡，把他压死了。巨石也会滚下来似乎不太可能，这只是巧合。无论如何，我不会去深究那个故事。他最终被压平了。是的。
Flattened his back. Exactly. He's flattened. And the two other people we should mention are Melinche's son by Hernan Cortes called Martin. He goes to Spain. He ends up becoming a page to Philip II of Spain. He joins the Spanish army, fights for the Spanish, comes back to Mexico, is involved in various sort of incomprehensible political plots and things, and ends up dying sometime
压平了他的背。没错。他被压平了。我们应该提到的另外两个人是马林切和埃尔南·科尔特斯的儿子，叫马丁。他去了西班牙。他最终成为西班牙腓力二世的侍从。他加入了西班牙军队，为西班牙而战，回到墨西哥，参与了各种难以理解的政治阴谋和事情，并最终在某个时候去世
towards the end of the 16th century. There was a statue of him put up, wasn't there? And Cortes and Malinche in Mexico City. That's right. Very controversial. And somebody stole the image of Martin and it's never been found. Yes. It was a very controversial statue because it was seen as celebrating European colonialism. And the other interesting character is a girl that we've mentioned a few times, 11 years old. Tequich Potzin. This is lordly daughter.
在16世纪末。有人立了一座他的雕像，不是吗？还有科尔特斯和马林切在墨西哥城。没错。非常有争议。有人偷走了马丁的形象，至今未被发现。是的。那是一座非常有争议的雕像，因为它被视为庆祝欧洲殖民主义。另一个有趣的角色是一个我们提到过几次的女孩，11岁。特基奇·波津。这是贵族女儿。
Lordly daughter, the daughter of Montezuma. She ended up living with cortez when cortez was in coia waka and cortez said come and live with me i shall look after you and basically she ended up having cortez's daughter so it's again it's quite a dark story leonore but actually her life ended by these standards it didn't end too badly she ended up being given a big estate because she was Montezuma's daughter. Yeah. So it's her legal right. She ended up with a massive estate. I think some people say the biggest in all of New Spain. And she lived there quietly with her daughter
贵族女儿，蒙特祖马的女儿。她最终和科尔特斯住在一起，当科尔特斯在科亚瓦卡时，科尔特斯说来和我住在一起，我会照顾你，基本上她最终生下了科尔特斯的女儿，所以这又是一个相当黑暗的故事，莱昂诺尔，但实际上她的生活按照这些标准结束得并不太坏，她最终得到了一大片庄园，因为她是蒙特祖马的女儿。是的。所以这是她的合法权利。她最终拥有了一大片庄园。我想有些人说这是整个新西班牙最大的。她和她的女儿在那里安静地生活
and actually seems to have been very popular with both Spaniards and indigenous people. And she died in 1551. So actually things ended better for her than you might have anticipated. A bright note on which to end that roundup. But of course, Dominic, we shouldn't forget lots and lots of nameless people, dead, raped, exploited. We said we mustn't forget them. No, no, no.
实际上似乎很受西班牙人和土著人的欢迎。她于1551年去世。所以实际上事情对她来说比你预期的要好。一个以光明音符结束总结的结尾。但当然，多米尼克，我们不应该忘记成千上万无名的人，死亡、强奸、剥削。我们说过我们绝不能忘记他们。不，不，不。
And of course, I mean, the big thing, the thing that underlies this whole story that matters more than any of the details we talked about is the coming of smallpox. That is the thing that tips the balance of the whole story and fundamentally alters the demographic picture of the Americas. Now, some people, sometimes when they tell that story, there's an element of blame, like it was the Europeans' fault for bringing smallpox. They should have known better and all this, but of course they have no concept. There was no way
当然，我的意思是，大事，贯穿整个故事、比我们谈论的任何细节都更重要的事情是天花的到来。那是使整个故事失去平衡并从根本上改变美洲人口状况的事情。现在，有些人，有时当他们讲述那个故事时，有一种指责的成分，好像把天花带进来是欧洲人的错。他们应该知道得更好，所有这些，但当然他们没有任何概念。没有办法
they weren't ever going to bring it. The Europeans were going to arrive at some point and when they did, these viruses were bound to come with them. And diseases are taken back across the Atlantic, aren't they? I mean, they're not as devastating. Well, this is the Columbian Exchange, isn't it, Tom? I mean, it's the landmark moments in human history when so many fruits, vegetables, seeds, animals, all these kinds of things are taken back and forth. And the new in the old world which are previously for thousands of years been detached from one another and ignorant of one another where they become united and it's often a very very dark story an obvious question could the mexica have maintained their independence this whole story has been a succession of moments where cortez is dodging a bullet, where the whole expedition could have been absolutely destroyed. Do you think there's
他们不可能不带进来。欧洲人迟早会到达，当他们到达时，这些病毒注定会随之而来。疾病被带回大西洋彼岸，不是吗？我的意思是，它们没有那么具有破坏性。好吧，这就是哥伦布大交换，不是吗，汤姆？我的意思是，这是人类历史上具有里程碑意义的时刻，当时如此多的水果、蔬菜、种子、动物，所有这些东西都被来回带走。新旧世界在几千年来彼此分离、彼此无知，现在它们变得统一，这通常是一个非常非常黑暗的故事，一个明显的问题，墨西哥人能保持他们的独立吗？整个故事是一连串科尔特斯躲避子弹的时刻，整个远征本可能被彻底摧毁。你认为有
any possibility that the Spanish wouldn't have come back even if Cortés' expedition had failed? It's the million-dollar question, really, isn't it? Could there still be a Mexica state with whom the Spanish have diplomatic relations or whatever? It's a really good question. We know from the New World more generally that every single corner of it was infiltrated by Europeans, wasn't it? And not just the Americas, Australia, New Zealand. Moctezuma is very able. We know that he plans, he's careful, he's very good at organization. He defeats Cortes. He finds Spaniards who are subornable enough that they can train his warriors. Does that change anything? I don't know. I'm slightly playing devil's advocate here because I think it was always going to happen. Yeah, no, I think it's a good question. I think,
任何可能性，即使科尔特斯的远征失败了，西班牙人也不会回来吗？这真的是价值百万美元的问题，不是吗？是否仍然可能存在一个墨西哥国家，与西班牙人有外交关系什么的？这是一个非常好的问题。我们从新世界更广泛地知道，它的每一个角落都被欧洲人渗透了，不是吗？不仅仅是美洲，澳大利亚，新西兰。蒙特祖马非常有能力。我们知道他有计划，他很小心，他非常擅长组织。他击败了科尔特斯。他找到了足够可以收买的西班牙人，让他们可以训练他的战士。这改变了什么吗？我不知道。我在这里稍微扮演魔鬼代言人，因为我认为这总是会发生的。是的，不，我认为这是一个好问题。我认为，
first of all, the fact that Mesoamerica is so divided means it's easy for the Spaniards and for any European power. Yeah, divide and rule. However it worked out, there would have been some constellation of forces that involved, you know, there would have been jockeying, there would have been geopolitical rivalry and stuff within Mesoamerica that would mean that it would be very hard for the big target, which is the empire of the Aztecs, to survive. That said, I suppose a good what-if would be, what if straight away, or at some point, Montezuma had done a deal with the Spaniards?
首先，中美洲如此分裂的事实意味着这对西班牙人和任何欧洲大国来说都很容易。是的，分而治之。无论结果如何，都会有某种力量组合，你知道，在中美洲内部会有争斗、地缘政治竞争什么的，这意味着大目标，也就是阿兹特克帝国，很难生存。话虽如此，我想一个好的“如果”是，如果蒙特祖马一开始或在某个时候与西班牙人达成协议会怎样？
What if he had surrendered to Charles V? Maybe not with Cortes, somebody as rapacious as Cortes, but what if, for example, he'd managed to do a deal with Diego Velasquez? He said, listen, let's not fight each other. I suppose then you're still faced with the same- You're being sucked into it, isn't it? You're being kind of ground into the churning machine that is the combination of legalism and militarism, which is so devastating. And Spanish sort of armed entrepreneurs, to use
如果他向查理五世投降了会怎样？也许不是和科尔特斯，像科尔特斯那样贪婪的人，但如果，例如，他设法与迭戈·委拉斯开兹达成协议呢？他说，听着，我们不要互相争斗。我想那时你仍然面临着同样的——你被卷进去了，不是吗？你被某种程度上磨进了作为法律主义和军国主义结合体的搅动机器中，这是如此具有破坏性。西班牙某种武装企业家，用
the phrase we've used before, Matthew Restall's phrase, they're still going to arrive, aren't they? I suppose you're then in the position of Native Americans in North America. And how important is it to world history that it's Christian Europeans who turn up? Well, I know your answer to that, Tom, but who else Christian Europeans who turn up? Well, I know your answer to that, Tom. But who else is going to turn up? Because the geographical proximity means that it's got to be people from the Atlantic seaboard. Your other plausible possibilities are what, the Chinese? The Chinese aren't going to do it, because we know that they turn against the idea of...
我们之前用过的短语，马修·雷斯托尔的短语，他们仍然会到达，不是吗？我想你那时处于北美美洲原住民的位置。基督教欧洲人出现对世界历史有多重要？好吧，我知道你的答案，汤姆，但还有谁基督教欧洲人出现？好吧，我知道你的答案，汤姆。但还有谁会来呢？因为地理上的接近意味着它必须是来自大西洋沿岸的人。你其他合理的可能性是什么，中国人？中国人不会这样做，因为我们知道他们反对……的想法
Muslim fleets? Muslim fleets, I suppose. Going from Morocco or... The Ottomans. Maybe the Ottomans would have sufficient... I mean, unlikely. But again, very unlikely. They're in the wrong geographical position.
穆斯林舰队？穆斯林舰队，我想。从摩洛哥出发或者……奥斯曼人。也许奥斯曼人会有足够的……我的意思是，不太可能。但同样，非常不可能。他们处于错误的地理位置。
It's hard to imagine. All right, reframe it. How important is it to the ability of Europeans to expand across the globe that they conquer Mexico? Does it establish a template? Oh, it definitely establishes a template. Yes, it absolutely does. It establishes a template for the Spanish to conquer the rest of the continent.
很难想象。好吧，重构它。欧洲人征服墨西哥对他们在全球扩张的能力有多重要？它建立了一个模板吗？哦，它绝对建立了一个模板。是的，它绝对做到了。它为西班牙征服大陆其余部分建立了一个模板。
It also obviously inspires everybody else to get in on the act. France, England. And the Protestants. Protestants, exactly. Of England and the Netherlands. Yes, exactly. I mean, actually, they do it quite late, don't they? I mean, it's remarkable how long it takes the English, for example. It just shows what a backwater England was in relative terms, that England takes so long to get up and firing. The interesting question is why the French are so slow. Well, they don't need to. That's the thing. They've got France. That's the thing. Why would you leave France? Which is also the reason the Ottomans don't do it and the Chinese.
它显然也激励了其他人参与其中。法国，英国。还有新教徒。新教徒，没错。英国和荷兰。是的，没错。我的意思是，实际上，他们做得相当晚，不是吗？我的意思是，英国人花了这么长时间才做到这一点是值得注意的。这只是表明英国在相对意义上是多么落后，英国花了这么长时间才开始行动。有趣的问题是为什么法国人这么慢。好吧，他们不需要。这就是重点。他们有法国。这就是重点。你为什么要离开法国？这也是为什么奥斯曼人和中国人不这样做。
Yeah. It's backward, poverty-stricken, Atlantic-facing, marginal states that have an interest in making this terrifying crossing over the Atlantic. Actually, funnily enough, it's why the Portuguese don't invest in Columbus. Yeah, because they've already got there. They've got their own sea routes going east. Why do they need to bother with this? And in a way, you could argue only the Spanish could have done this. It obviously transforms Spain's place in the world economy,
是的。这是落后、贫困、面向大西洋、边缘化的国家，有兴趣进行这次穿越大西洋的可怕航行。实际上，有趣的是，这就是为什么葡萄牙人不投资哥伦布。是的，因为他们已经到了那里。他们有自己的向东航线。他们为什么要费心做这个？在某种程度上，你可以说只有西班牙人能做到这一点。它显然改变了西班牙在世界经济中的地位，
turns Spain into a superpower, the flow of gold, although the flow of gold ends up being very destabilizing because of the massive European inflation. Whether there's any scenario, to go back to your earlier thing, whether there is any scenario that involves the new world holding out against old world colonization, I find that utterly implausible. Yeah, I do. Because I think once they've developed the technology, the ships with the famous triangular sails, Tom, and other such things, once they've developed the technology to get across, the sheer competitiveness of European states plus the entrepreneurship and the acquisitiveness,
使西班牙成为超级大国，黄金的流动，尽管黄金的流动最终因为大规模的欧洲通货膨胀而变得非常不稳定。回到你之前提到的，是否有任何涉及新世界抵御旧世界殖民的场景，我发现这完全不可信。是的，我也这么认为。因为我认为一旦他们开发了技术，带有著名三角帆的船只，汤姆，以及其他类似的东西，一旦他们开发了穿越的技术，欧洲国家的纯粹竞争性加上个人的企业家精神和贪婪，
the greed, basically, of individuals means that they are always going to come in greater and greater numbers. And the biological balance favours them because they're smallpox. So one final question to go back to your book. Yes. The Fall of the Aztecs. Brilliant note on which to end, Tom. I get a sense reading some of the best scholars on this theme that it's not just that they are hostile to European colonialism, but they're hostile to the very drama and excitement of the narratives. So Matthew Restle, who is, I think think by far the most brilliant of these scholars in his book he writes about cortez yeah and he says of course there's this tradition in which he is you know cast as a saintly figure he's a hero the center of this great drama and then he talks of
基本上是贪婪，意味着他们总是会以越来越多的人数到来。生物平衡偏向他们，因为有天花。所以最后一个问题回到你的书。是的。《阿兹特克的陨落》。以一个精彩的音符结束，汤姆。我阅读了一些关于这个主题的最优秀学者的作品，感觉到他们不仅对欧洲殖民主义怀有敌意，而且对叙事本身的戏剧性和兴奋感也怀有敌意。所以马修·雷斯托尔，我认为他是这些学者中最杰出的，在他的书中他写到了科尔特斯，是的，他说当然有这种传统，他被塑造成一个圣人形象，他是英雄，这个伟大戏剧的中心，然后他谈到
course there's this other tradition that he is cast as a villain a kind of satanic figure and he rejects both of them and says that they situate him at the center of a great drama and they burnish his renown. And therefore he says, firstly, Cortez is a mediocrity. He's the plaything of forces and factions that he's just kind of tossed about willy-nilly. And secondly, he deconstructs the narrative so completely that he's essentially saying we have no possibility of knowing what the narrative is. Yeah. And that seems to me just as important, that if you can deconstruct this narrative that we've actually been telling, then you leech it off the sense of excitement. That even if you
当然还有另一种传统，他被塑造成一个恶棍，一种撒旦形象，他拒绝了两者，并说他们把他置于伟大戏剧的中心，并擦亮了他的名声。因此他说，首先，科尔特斯是一个平庸之辈。他是力量和派系的玩物，他只是被随意地抛来抛去。其次，他如此彻底地解构了叙事，以至于他基本上是在说我们没有可能知道叙事是什么。是的。这对我来说同样重要，如果你能解构我们一直在讲述的这个叙事，那么你就从中抽离了兴奋感。即使你
are horrified by what's happening, I mean, you can't help but feel that this is a gripping narrative. And there's a sense in which now the very idea of this being a narrative is something that should be opposed. I think you're absolutely right. I mean, you've engaged with his writings quite heavily in your own writing, but you were basically doing the absolute opposite of what he's doing because you are presenting a narrative that can be understood by children. So in a sense, you have to cut out nuance doubt yes all the kind of the haze of uncertainty that surrounds these narratives you're absolutely right tom and it opens up loads of different questions so one of them is about the difference in writing for children and for adults
对正在发生的事情感到震惊，我的意思是，你忍不住觉得这是一个扣人心弦的叙事。在某种意义上，现在这种作为叙事的想法本身就是应该被反对的东西。我认为你是绝对正确的。我的意思是，你在你自己的写作中非常深入地参与了他的著作，但你基本上是在做与他所做的完全相反的事情，因为你正在呈现一个孩子们可以理解的叙事。所以从某种意义上说，你必须切断细微差别、怀疑，是的，所有围绕这些叙事的模糊不确定性，你是绝对正确的，汤姆，它打开了许多不同的问题，所以其中之一是关于为儿童和成人写作的区别
you've written for children yourself of course your wolf girl i have a book about the greeks the gods and so on and as you know, when you are writing for children, the demands are very different. Children are not stupid, so you're not dumbing down for them necessarily. But a child reader who is reading a book voluntarily for pleasure, when they could be reading Harry Potter or playing a video game or whatever, they will tire very quickly of you saying, now some historians think that. Yeah, but not to dwell on that, rather to dwell on the fact that this is one of the stories that you've chosen to tell. So you've done the world wars, you've done Alexander, you've done Cleopatra. These are the great classic stories.
你自己也为孩子们写过书，当然你的《狼女孩》，我有一本关于希腊人、神等等的书，正如你所知，当你为孩子们写作时，要求是非常不同的。孩子们并不笨，所以你并不一定是在为他们降低智力。但是一个自愿为了乐趣而阅读一本书的儿童读者，当他们本可以阅读《哈利·波特》或玩电子游戏什么的，他们会很快厌倦你说，现在一些历史学家认为。是的，但不要纠结于此，而是纠结于这是你选择讲述的故事之一。所以你做过世界大战，你做过亚历山大，你做过克利奥帕特拉。这些都是伟大的经典故事。
So a distrust of telling this story. This, I would say, is the single most astonishing narrative that we've done in all the episodes, all the topics that we've covered in The Rest is History, the risks that Cortez takes, but also for the drama of this kind of unique meeting of two great powers from different worlds, kind of almost different time zones. I mean, are scholars who are, for entirely understandable reasons, very, very ideologically opposed to everything that, say, Cortes represents. Are they justified in being nervous of the sheer drama of this story? I think they are justified in being nervous. I understand why they're doing it, because they're
所以对讲述这个故事的不信任。我会说，这是我们在《历史的其余部分》中做的所有剧集、我们涵盖的所有主题中最令人震惊的叙事，科尔特斯冒的风险，但也因为这种来自不同世界、几乎不同时区的两个大国独特会面的戏剧性。我的意思是，那些出于完全可以理解的原因，在意识形态上非常非常反对科尔特斯所代表的一切的学者。他们有理由对这个故事的纯粹戏剧性感到紧张吗？我认为他们有理由感到紧张。我理解他们为什么这样做，因为他们
being nervous for ideological reasons, as you say. So Matthew Restore, for example, is explicit in his book in saying, I want to take out the glamour from this story and the melodrama. I want to show it as a horrible... He loathes Cortes. He hates the Spanish project, if you like. He thinks it represents rape, torture, slavery, exploitation, all of these things. I don't think I'm putting words in his mouth. And he would say to tell it in a kind of roaring swashbuckling style is to give them what they want is to miss what he sees as the horrible realism of the story so is that what we've done in the series i think when the rest is history and actually not just on the rest is history i think lots of historical work more generally has its cake and eats it doesn't it and i think we're
出于意识形态的原因感到紧张，正如你所说。所以马修·雷斯托尔，例如，在他的书中明确表示，我想从这个故事中去除魅力和情节剧。我想把它展示为一个可怕的……他厌恶科尔特斯。他讨厌西班牙项目，如果你愿意的话。他认为它代表强奸、酷刑、奴隶制、剥削，所有这些事情。我不认为我在替他说话。他会说，以一种咆哮的、剑侠风格来讲述它就是给他们想要的，就是错过了他所看到的这个故事的可怕现实主义，所以这就是我们在系列中所做的吗？我认为当《历史的其余部分》以及实际上不仅仅是在《历史的其余部分》，我认为许多历史作品更广泛地既要又要，不是吗？我认为我们
both probably being guilty of that in our own writings. So when I think about, I mean, on a totally different note, you know, you often tease me about my books on the 60s saying, you know, most people were listening to the sound of music and eating chicken Kiev or whatever, and not actually having fun at all. Hanging out on Carnaby Street. But I have my cake and eat it in those books. I have long descriptions of Carnaby Street and the Beatles and all of that stuff. While also saying, actually, most people have very humdrum lives. Just like you, when you write about the Romans, and you tell the most fantastic stories about the emperors, and you also then say, ah, but we know this probably, you know, these are from sources that were party pre or whatever.
可能在我们的写作中都有罪。所以当我想到，我的意思是，在完全不同的音符上，你知道，你经常取笑我关于60年代的书，说，你知道，大多数人都在听《音乐之声》和吃基辅鸡什么的，实际上根本没有玩得开心。在卡纳比街闲逛。但在那些书中，我既要又要。我有关于卡纳比街和披头士乐队以及所有这些东西的长篇描述。同时也说，实际上，大多数人过着非常平淡的生活。就像你一样，当你写关于罗马人的时候，你讲述了关于皇帝的最奇妙的故事，然后你也说，啊，但我们知道这可能，你知道，这些来自有偏见的来源什么的。
But you see, I think doing it now, and just I'm thinking aloud, really, thinking how I feel about the story that we've been telling. I think actually I would come at a slightly different conclusion, which is that humans love these kinds of stories. Of course they do, Tom. Even if the stories end in tragedy and horror, we still love them. So throughout these episodes, you know, there've been echoes of Greek tragedy, biblical accounts of the fall of Jerusalem, classical history. And these are great stories as well.
但你看，我认为现在这样做，我只是在自言自语，真的，思考我对我们一直在讲述的故事的感觉。我认为实际上我会得出一个稍微不同的结论，那就是人类喜欢这类故事。当然他们喜欢，汤姆。即使故事以悲剧和恐怖告终，我们仍然喜欢它们。所以贯穿这些剧集，你知道，有希腊悲剧、圣经中耶路撒冷陷落的记载、古典历史的回声。这些也是伟大的故事。
And the horror is interfused with the drama and the excitement. And I think there is no escaping from the fact that the horror isn't something that can be divorced from the drama. It's kind of interfused. I totally agree with you, Tom. I totally agree. And it says something unsettling, perhaps, about human nature and about human desire for stories. what most of them will crave is action, excitement. They love the horror, by the way. I mean, I know because I go into schools to talk to groups, sometimes quite small children,
恐怖与戏剧性和兴奋感交织在一起。我认为无法逃避这样一个事实，即恐怖不是可以与戏剧性分开的东西。它是一种交织。我完全同意你的观点，汤姆。我完全同意。这说明了关于人性以及人类对故事的渴望的一些令人不安的事情。他们大多数人渴望的是行动、兴奋。顺便说一句，他们喜欢恐怖。我的意思是，我知道因为我走进学校与团体交谈，有时是相当小的孩子，
children eight or nine or something. They can't get enough of Henry VIII having an enema, or people having their heads chopped off by the guillotine, or whatever it might be. Now, we all laugh about that. We say, our kids, they're very bloodthirsty. But actually, adults are no different. If you look at the podcasts that we've done that get the most, you know, the Nazis. But I think with this, there's another reason why it's such an incredible story, which is that there is heroism on both sides. Yeah, agreed. So Cortez, whatever you think about him, I mean, he's clearly a horrible person,
八九岁的孩子什么的。他们对亨利八世灌肠，或者人们被断头台砍掉头颅，或者无论它可能是什么，都看不够。现在，我们都对此大笑。我们说，我们的孩子，他们非常嗜血。但实际上，成年人没有什么不同。如果你看看我们做的那些获得最多的播客，你知道，纳粹。但我认为对于这个，还有另一个原因，为什么它是一个如此不可思议的故事，那就是双方都有英雄主义。是的，同意。所以科尔特斯，无论你怎么看他，我的意思是，他显然是一个可怕的人，
but his courage and his willingness to gamble makes it almost impossible to read what's happening and not feel a sense of admiration for him. And I think also what has happened, particularly with the brilliant scholars who are writing about the Mexica, the Aztecs now, we have a much better understanding of what made their civilization tick and a sense of the wonder of it. And the tragedy when they lose. Yes. And so that's the essence, I guess, of a tragedy or a great story is that you can read about this or listen to this story and identify with the boldness of what Cortes is attempting and feel the kind of grief for the horror that is visited on this extraordinary civilization. And you can feel both at the same time. And that's part of the power, perhaps, uniquely of this story. I can't think of anything where that
但他的勇气和赌博的意愿使得阅读正在发生的事情而不对他产生一种钦佩感几乎是不可能的。而且我认为也发生了什么，特别是对于那些正在撰写关于墨西哥人、阿兹特克人的杰出学者，我们现在对是什么让他们的文明运转有了更好的理解，并对它的奇迹有了感觉。当他们失败时的悲剧。是的。所以这就是悲剧或伟大故事的本质，我想，你可以阅读这个或听这个故事，并认同科尔特斯所尝试的大胆，并为这个非凡文明所遭受的恐怖感到悲伤。你可以同时感受到两者。这也许是这个故事独特力量的一部分。我想不出有什么东西能让那个
tension is quite so strong. I agree completely, Tom. And actually, my publisher said to me, when you write the preface to your book, you should point this out. So I have a couple of lines. I'll just read it. The fall of the Aztecs is often a very bloody story. For centuries, people used to tell it as a clash between wicked Aztecs and gallant Spaniards. These days, it's more common to tell it from the opposite angle, casting the Aztecs as noble underdogs and the Spanish conquerors as greedy monsters. But I don't see it that way. There was plenty of cruelty on both sides, but plenty of courage too.
这种紧张感非常强烈。我完全同意，汤姆。事实上，我的出版商曾对我说，当你写书的序言时，你应该指出这一点。所以我写了几行，我读一下：阿兹特克人的覆灭往往是一个非常血腥的故事。几个世纪以来，人们习惯将其描述为邪恶的阿兹特克人和英勇的西班牙人之间的冲突。如今，人们更倾向于从相反的角度来讲述，将阿兹特克人描绘成高尚的弱者，而将西班牙征服者描绘成贪婪的怪物。但我并不这么看。双方都有很多残忍的行为，但也都有很多勇气。
Was Montezuma a hero? Was Cortez a villain? Or was it the other way around? Who were more bloodthirsty, the Aztecs or the Spaniards? Or is it a bit simplistic to think of them that way? Wise words. And I think that's exactly the approach that actually we should take as historians writing about this. To see these people as actors in a world where they're very confused, they're trying to make sense of what's going on. It's an unprecedented situation. There are heroes and villains on both sides. Of course, the Spanish win. And so the Spanish behavior afterwards is immensely shocking to us.
蒙特祖马是英雄吗？科尔特斯是恶棍吗？还是反过来？谁更嗜血，阿兹特克人还是西班牙人？或者说，以这种方式看待他们是否有点过于简单化了？说得好。我认为这正是我们作为历史学家在撰写这段历史时应该采取的方法。将这些人视为一个世界中的行动者，他们感到非常困惑，试图理解正在发生的事情。这是一个前所未有的局面。双方都有英雄和恶棍。当然，西班牙人赢了。所以西班牙人随后的行为让我们感到极其震惊。
But at the same time, the Aztecs are not, it's easy to turn them into saintly martyrs, but of course they weren't. I mean, there are lots of people in Mesoamerica who absolutely loathed, like Malinche, who loathed the Aztecs. And actually getting that complexity across is the key to the story. Well, thank you, Dominic. So your book, The Fall of the Aztecs, is out and available in Good Book Shops. Make an ideal Christmas present for any historically enthused children out there. And thank you so much for this brilliant account of this extraordinary episode in history. And
但与此同时，阿兹特克人并非——很容易把他们变成圣洁的殉道者，但他们当然不是。我的意思是，中美洲有很多人绝对痛恨阿兹特克人，比如马林切。事实上，传达这种复杂性才是这个故事的关键。好的，谢谢你，多米尼克。你的书《阿兹特克人的覆灭》已经出版，在各大书店均有销售。对于任何热爱历史的孩子来说，这都是一份理想的圣诞礼物。非常感谢你对这段非凡历史的精彩讲述。还有
thank you very much if you have made it this far very grateful to you for accompanying us on this mighty epic thanks so much thank you very much tom has been very indulgent and very patient i have to say haven't i think it's a brilliant story well i've always been obsessed by this story as i think anyone interested in history must be all right so i'm absolutely thrilled that we've done it so on that note goodbye everybody goodbye everybody. Goodbye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews,
非常感谢你能坚持听到这里，非常感谢你陪伴我们走过这段宏大的史诗，非常感谢，非常感谢。汤姆一直非常包容和耐心，我必须说，不是吗？我认为这是一个精彩的故事。好吧，我一直对这个故事着迷，我想任何对历史感兴趣的人都一定会着迷。所以，我非常高兴我们完成了它。那么，再见大家，再见大家。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余谈》。这是你们每周的娱乐新闻、评论、
splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
一点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们会揭开娱乐界的幕后，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集以及抢先收听权限。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。